Well, you know, about the history of Christmas. Do you know of any,
I know it's a relatively recent phenomenon. I mean,
the idea that you would celebrate a birthday is also very modern in
Christianity. Your,
your birthday was assigned to the Christian name that you
received.
So there'd be the th th th the day of the Saint for after whom you're
named. And so I was Christian, but there's no Saint Neil. So I was actually.
No matter when you go there, you're going to Canada.
Uh, this, I don't think anybody knows this. My, uh,
my baptismal certificate says Cornelius, because there's a Saint Cornelius,
Cornelius de Grasse Tyson in the baptismal certificate,
but I'm otherwise Neal in my birth certificate. So, so your,
your, your birth was celebrated on the day, uh, ascribed to that Saint.
Um, so the idea of giving birth giving presence for a birthday is a,
is a relatively new now Christmas. All right.
This was a brilliant maneuver by the Catholic church back
when all Christians were Catholic. And so what do you do?
You got all these pagans that running around, uh,
they're doing their pagan stuff, dancing naked around them.
Bonfire, pagan stuff. That's exactly what I was going to do with that,
with your masterclass. I mean,
the pagans partied a lot better than the Christians. So here's what happened.
So one of the set celebrations, um,
w took place a few days after the first day of winter.
Okay. So, uh, today we're around that time, we're on the first day of winter.
Well, what's happening. I don't know if you noticed, but as the winter,
as you approach winter, the sun,
the arc of the sun from sunrise to sunset gets lower and lower in the sky
as the days go by. That's when the sun and it's in the summer,
sun is very high in the mid day in the winter. It's very low. Shadows are long.
The ancients notice this as you approach December 21st,
the arc got lower and lower and lower. And your sun worshiping civilization.
This is some scary stuff. Okay. Because if this keeps going,
the sun will dip below the horizon and never come up again. That's scary.
So what do you, do you pray to your gods and this,
the movement of the sun slows down. It stops.
So STIs, stationary,
sun armistice, stationary arms. Okay.
But it's Latin soul is the sun. This stops. So the sun stops getting lower.
And then you begin to notice it come back up.
That happens a few days after December 21st,
that happens around December 25th celebrations abound.
Now you want everyone to be monotheistic? Not multi-feed not,
um, Polly polytheistic.
So what you do is you co-opt
preexisting celebrations, smart move, just weren't moving. Yeah. Tactical,
tactical, marketing, strategic, all of the above. So you say, well,
um, while the birth of Jesus, we think of as a very important event today,
nowhere near as important as Easter, Easter,
that's the cannon right there.
That Jesus dying on the cross for your sins.
The fact that he was born is kind of incidental. Everyone's born,
not really Jesus Christ yet. He didn't do his miracles. He's a, did a baby.
Right. All right. So, but it was still an unassigned holiday.
So let's put the birth of Jesus. There it's an unknown date, by the way,
they think it might've been sometime in the spring based on descriptions,
shepherd, shepherd, shepherds. But, uh, and when they make the pecorino cheese.
Yeah. Surfing
[inaudible] gospel of Luke.
Um, so, uh,
so th th do you assign that now you can port people over
from whatever was the previous celebration to a Christian celebration,
and that enabled it to take a firm hold and Santa Claus would come much
later. Of course.
Well, what Santa Claus started to come?
It's actually like anything else that happens great in this country,
it came out of New York city, baby 18th century, late 18th century, Thomas Nast.
He was a, um, uh, uh, civil war, union propaganda artist. And he created,
um, the, the idea of the image image.
It was really a union soldier with toy that weren't toys. It was like, um,
what was it in his sack? It was a military military equipment.
And 10 to midnight thing was like,
Senate is running out of time to re-enlist soldiers.
It's it was a whole propaganda read this long ago, but I forgotten all about it.
[inaudible] if I remember that illustration is very textured and rich. Yeah.
It's like totally in, right. I mean, he looks like a, just a drunk Irish kid.
Yeah, he does. He's just drunk.
Irish kid name should be showing he Donald. Yeah.
Their traditions and rituals, we think are deep and long ago, but no,
somebody just invented them. Right. And,
and even the Christmas tree is a secular thing. It's just the, uh,
but it was attached to the Christmas holidays. And so now you've got,
so the plenty of Jewish people have Christmas trees, right? Oh, no.
I grew up in Brooklyn Jews, a lot of Jews, my,
all my Jewish friends at Christmas trees. So you're Jewish, Greek,
I'm all Greek. But my friends, you said you were fourth Turkish.
We got at the beginning of 26%, 26%. Now that counts as a force.
And that's what answer by the way.
26 Days. No, no, you're not getting 26 that's they told me no,
it's twenty-five twenty-five. Yeah, because you only,
you can only split by twos, right? So you're 50%. Twenty-five percent,
12 and a half percent, one eighth, one 16th. You're not getting 26% 25,
unless you are Greek so long ago.
That it's split into a hundred parts and you can divide it that closest.
And you're one fourth grade I'm 100% African
[inaudible] exploded. St. Nick was actually Turkey before use for you, baby.
It's a Turkish kid.
Saint Nicholas was born in two 88 D and petard on the Amidah in modern day
Turkey. So what are you going to do now? Touch wood. Again,
we really hope you enjoy it.
That episode, whatever it was about,
this is just a stock thing that we're taping on temporary episode.
So go make sure you rate, review us, subscribe,
turn on your notifications, get jiggy with it and go to.
Tron.com/bay Ridge boys, where things get really wild.